hey youtubers is Charlie big news vixens
coming to legends of tomorrow season 2
so I'm gonna explain what's going on and
what that might look like there are a
couple other cast members that they're
also still looking for so vixen is going
to be a series regular for season 2
meaning she's gonna be in most if not
all of the episodes but the problem is
is that the actress Mae Callen who I'm
just gonna call that's her twitter
handle Megha Lin isn't available because
she's booked on another project so
they're gonna have to do a different
version of vixen
they said she'll just be from somewhere
else in the timeline like an earlier
version of the character there have been
other people to use the totem like
that's the way they write her lore vixen
is just the latest person in her family
to wear the totem so presumably this new
character will be her ancestor which I
still think is a huge upgrade for the
show just getting one more powerful
character with actual superpowers some
of my complaints against legends of
tomorrow season one were in people and
things that they left out just because
it felt like maybe they didn't have the
okay to do that now that Jeff Jones is
the Kevin Feige of DC's movies and
they're doing Superman on Supergirl
they're doing just the society on
legends of tomorrow I think they have
access to characters they normally
wouldn't have been able to do before but
they haven't really said too much about
the stories they're gonna be doing other
than the villain will be a big upgrade
from Vandal Savage as well and I think
Vandal Savage was a great villain for
season 1 but there were some problems
with the way he was written in the way
the story used him that they tried to
combine Vandal Savage
with Seth hat from the Hawkman Hawkgirl
comic books and they're two completely
different things so I think it just did
end up being quite as awesome as it
could have been and a lot of that has to
do with the actors that they cast in the
speed with which they were trying to get
episodes out I think the whole first
season was just way too rushed so are
they now by upgrading their cast as well
as spending a lot of extra time working
on those scripts and figuring out what
the arc of the seasons gonna be it'll be
a lot more fun so if you haven't watched
legends of tomorrow season one yet I
would recommend you at least watch the
finale just so you get that Justice
Society tease and just to explain that
so spoiler warning for legends season 1
as they defeat Vandal Savage and
everyone kind of starts to go their
separate ways a version of the Waverider
from the future comes crashing down in
out walks our man telling rip hunter you
sent me I'm from the Justice Society of
Erica so presumably something is
happening in the future to the siping
catastrophe they haven't explained it
yet but that's what the main arc of
season 2 is gonna be but that's just
legends of tomorrow even though they're
doing the four night crossover there'll
be just the society things involving all
the TV shows legends is the one that's
going really deep into that so because
they've done so many weird things on the
flash we've seen alternate universes
we've gone backwards and forwards in
time we've changed the timeline in
really weird ways we've seen Speed Force
wormhole aliens I think it's a pretty
safe bet that we will see like future
versions of all these characters on the
TV shows inside the Justice Society like
we'll see future Oliver Queen future
Supergirl future flash all on the
Justice Society all the stars are going
back to work in a couple weeks so
hopefully they'll have some footage to
show off at Comic Con and we'll have
some Justice League promo art to show
off of all the characters around the
table or earn the light up however they
want to do it it's just that when they
do big promos like that they've had a
history of doing comic book coverage
like the flash of two worlds comic book
cover so hopefully they'll do it just to
society comic book cover but here's my
question for you guys who do you think
the big bill and upgrade is gonna be and
because they have vixen I'm still kind
of thinking more drew he's like the
biggest magic user that you could think
of that they'd be able to do on the TV
shows probably not gonna doom in the
movie so that's not really an issue but
that just seems like the easiest way to
one-up Vandal Savage and if they have
vixen that means they want a magic user
on the team it would make sense that
magic would have something to do with
the season to arc so they haven't really
said anything about casting a lot of the
show's they've been talking a lot about
the people they're casting for arrow the
big arrow villain Stephen Amell has been
teasing things I'll talk a little bit
about that in a separate video but they
haven't quite started talking about
flash characters they're casting or
legends of tomorrow so once we learn
about that we'll have a better idea but
I think that's right around the corner
and I know it is a bit of a bummer that
they can't get the same actress that
they came on arrow to do vixen to come
back but she's booked she's still doing
the voice for the animated series and
they are doing a second season of that
so if you haven't seen it it's on the CW
seed it's like CW see calm it's 30
minutes broken into five minute episode
so it's basically like one thirty minute
episode so that's kind of how season 2
is going to be as well and they'll
probably premiere it the same way they
did last year where they bill
up to the first episode of arrow and
flash and all that stuff that's coming
back so I'm just gonna affectionately
call Legends season 2 Justice Society
and I know they probably should have
done that with the show originally but
that was before all the Batman V
Superman drama the behind the scenes
shuffle now I think the TV shows have a
little more freedom with the stories
they tell and the way they use
characters so I'm really excited about
the next season of all these different
shows I'll be doing bonus videos for
everything all summer so no worries be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm also gonna start a new round of the
giveaway now - it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll just announce the winner
the next time I post a DC video so in
case I don't get to it right away the
arrow villain that everyone was talking
about for next season is supposed to be
a stringer Bell wire type character so
that means something of a gentleman drug
dealer who's generally physically
imposing someone who you believe could
go toe-to-toe in a fight with Oliver
Queen so I will try to do a video later
this week just explaining that because
if you've ever seen any of my arrow
videos I always compare to the wire
because the writers of arrow are so in
love with the wire so that show was
already kind of conceived as DC's
version of The Wire so if you haven't
seen the wire from HBO that actually
probably be helpful to watch that
especially the later seasons that deal
more with what's going on inside the
mayor's office because we're gonna be
doing mayor Oliver Queen so I feel like
they're going to be taking a lot of
inspiration from the wire next season so
why you guys wait for that next video to
post you can click here for my Deadpool
kills x-men apocalypse video and you can
click here to learn all about Superman
coming to Supergirl season 2 like an
actual Superman so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight